probably when this episode comes out
probably a couple of weeks ago
um Mr Andrew Tate has been banned off
the socials I know Andrew come back
good he followed me and I was he was
supposed to come on
he's gonna come on my show he can still
come on your show yeah but how do I get
in contact with him
not Instagram that's actually a very
good point I didn't actually think of oh
um I was gonna say he's University he's
online university but you'd have to pay
to get access oh you can't even join
because you're a woman
really yes men only
huh okay I think it's meant only you
should try though yeah okay but if you
followed you then he obviously knows who
you are so it's still worth yeah that's
all we're doing what do you think about
the kind of stuff that he says around
dating between men and women and how
things should work by his standards I
mean I think he speaks a lot of facts to
be honest yeah I mean like
um
I mean just like anyone I don't agree
with anyone anything that anyone says
like everything that anyone says but
yeah
kind of weird you have to disclaim that
yeah you know what I mean like that's
kind of implied you don't agree with
every like I don't agree with every
single thing kit says but I would have
to disclaim that oh she really doesn't
we've had it but but you know what I'm
saying it's kind of weird you have to
say that when someone's controversial
yeah but you you agree with the the
Foundation of his message they call me
Andrea Kate Andrew okay
on Tick Tock don't put like Andrea KW
that's so funny I think um I think
in regards to his content I understand
why he says a lot of what he says
I think there is something about
what he advocates for only applies to
for the very small percentage of men
true and like the truth is in life not
everybody can be a winner like and this
is something that um what's his name
shnico sneaker sneako yeah
because I watched the debate between him
and Abba and sneaker was like no
everybody can be rich everybody can be
whatever and it's like well no because
if everyone's Rich then no one's Rich do
you know what I mean think about it
everyone's Rich today everyone's a
winner
we're richer then we have a higher
standard of living than anyone has in
all of human history yeah when you think
about it everyone's a winner today
well ever yeah that has to be losers
right not really comparisons the thief
of Joy like I'm telling you you take
someone from 500 years ago place them
today they're thinking they're living
the freaking life even if they're poor
it's so true and it's like but like we
compare and we're like oh well that
guy's richer than me even though
everyone's winning well what I would say
while I agree with that when it comes to
dating that doesn't work the same
so what I mean is it's not like
because it's all relative and that's
what I'm trying to say in terms of
winning or losing Whatever by by
normal standards or historical standards
yeah everybody's doing way better than
anyone else but like at the end of the
day like
it doesn't matter if everybody who runs
the 100 meters today is faster than the
fastest person 80 years ago in dating
well in dating what I mean is like
the percentage is still the same in
terms of it's only a top percentage of
men right well yeah that's what I'm
saying because it goes back to
comparison because if you go to a
percentage like if you want to say one
percent like that's a percentage so
there's only so many people that can
like be in one percent but it doesn't
make everyone else a loser it's just how
you Strat like it's how you look at it
very true so you could argue everyone's
winning today but I would say going back
to Andrew Tate's message that the way he
says to operate especially as a man only
really speaks for the pers the top
percentage it's not about it's not about
what you have today it's about the
percentage I don't know so I was
thinking about this a little bit um
foreign
I feel like I'm gonna get corrected but
but in Nigeria isn't it common to have
multiple wives and like certain
countries like that well so it's in
Islam it is and Nigeria is primarily
more Christian but there is there's a
community of Muslim like oh because I
was like I swear I've met a couple
people from Nigeria and they're like
grandpa or something had like multiple
wives or like so my my grandfather's
grandfather did oh no my grandfather's
father did yes yes but he was Muslim so
it's more of a religious thing as
opposed to like a cultural thing I don't
know I think I don't even think it's
like money like I think
there's so many bombs that they might
they have multiple baby mamas they may
as well have multiple wives
well you could you could and they're
sleeping with all of them they they and
they don't have to pay for them yeah
like I guess child support they kind of
do but
it's like basically multiple wives yeah
no it's true I mean only less than half
of men have ever reproduced anyway yeah
no I know yeah
um something that you said on your
channel you said about women who say men
are trash
is the same as men say all women are
[ __ ] yeah
um can you elaborate on that what do you
mean by that well it's like okay if you
think men are trash the men you've dealt
with are probably trash and it's
probably because you can't attract the
men that aren't trash and if you if you
say women are [ __ ] it's probably
because all the women you've dealt with
are [ __ ] and you can't attract the
women that aren't [ __ ] yeah
I mean yeah I can't disagree with that
logic do you not think there's an
element of um
because I think sometimes different
women say different women say men are
trash for different reasons and I think
I've heard a lot of women Express all
menotash because they don't want to want
to commit right
while sexual Liberation is
um has been great in many circumstances
what it's inadvertently done is while
it's liberated women sexually it's given
the power to the top percentage of men
so
so in that
because if they've you know they say if
you want to test a man's character you
give him power
um
is maybe not just those decisions that
men not decide to commit as a result of
just the landscape that the dating is
now as opposed to because they're bad
people do you know what I mean yeah I
don't think they're bad people if you
okay if you put a hunter
[Laughter]
girl the girls don't read why men love
[ __ ] they love this analogy because
it's Steve Harvey the hunter yeah and
you give him more than one prey that are
on a silver platter on Tinder
and he eats multiple deer gazelle yeah
can you blame him you put it on a you
can't blame him you can't blame him
just like if a girl gets asked out by a
millionaire and more than one
millionaire asks her on a date and she
goes on two dates yeah like
I mean she's hypergamous let's talk
about abortion mm-hmm
the whole Roe v Wade overturned you know
all of this what are your what's your
thoughts on abortion I know this is kind
of more political but I think it'd be a
good topic for us to talk about
um I think that abortion is bad you
think it's bad you think it should be
illegal yeah you do if it was in Pearl's
world yeah I don't think it'll ever be
100 illegal but yeah if it was up to me
why do you
because
I I my stance is very much to each their
own so even if
you know even if I had a partner and we
were like we'd never get an abortion
that is like if if someone wants to down
the road wants to do it let her do it do
you know what I mean